[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette semaine je sais pas si votre fil
de nouvelles et comme le mien mais j'ai
les yeux de tourner présentement vers le
Manitoba non seulement parce qu'on a
découvert un nouveau tueur en série
actif au Canada mais encore une fois
malheureusement on trouve une
corrélation entre en série et des
victimes qui sont majoritairement des
femmes autochtones pourquoi on en parle
beaucoup cette semaine c'est que trois
des présumés victimes de cet homme
serait enfoui dans un site
d'enfouissement de déchets dans le nord
de Winnipeg c'est trois victimes c'est
Morgane Harris c'est Mercedes merren et
la troisième personne qui est pas
identifié a été nommée Buffalo woman par
les aînés au Manitoba et ces trois
personnes sont en fous dans un site dans
le fond d'enfouissement qui est
différent de la quatrième victime qui
avait été trouvée et le problème
performance c'est que la relation qui se
trouve déjà problématique entre les
communautés autochtones et la GRC est
encore plus problématisée par le fait
que la police a dit que c'était
infaisable de trouver les restes de ces
femmes-là dans un site dans ce suicide
dans ce moment-là particulier
bien sûr vous comprendrez que ça choque
énormément la communauté de Winnipeg et
les membres des communautés du Manitoba
non seulement parce que ça continue
cette déshumanisation des femmes
autochtones mais c'est vraiment parce
que il y a pas une mobilisation à grande
échelle il y a pas non plus un
réveil collectif comme on pourra en
avoir et je tiens à dire en tout respect
ça vient quand même
au Québec en même temps ces nouvelles
vient en même temps que aussi la
commémoration autour des victimes de la
Polytechnique donc les féminicides
qu'elles soient à l'octones ou
autochtones sont importants à noter mais
ne sont pas souvent le crépi ou ne sont
pas non plus
pris à partie de la même manière donc on
voit dans cette espèce de décision de la
police de ne pas faire des fouilles pour
trouver le corps de ces femmes là comme
vraiment encore une fois l'idée que les
vies autochtones valent vraiment moins
que les vies à l'automne imaginez si on
trouve on vous disait qu'on n'irait pas
chercher les restes de votre mère votre
sort votre voisine tout simplement parce
que c'est pas possible je pense qu'il y
aurait une mobilisation qui se ferait
ici alors je pense que il y a quelque
chose où est-ce qu'on a eu le même Fada
on a eu la commission d'enquête pour les
femmes assassinés disparu mais on voit
encore des situations telles que
celle-là se produire c'est très
difficile pour nous en tant que femme
autochtone de sentir qu'on qu'on a une
valeur au Canada si
à tous les niveaux on n'est pas respecté
protégé qu'on n'a pas même ce droit à la
dignité humaine de ne pas avoir nos
restes laissés dans des sites
d'enfouissement
il y a quelque chose qui est calculé
là-dedans dans nos esprits puisque c'est
quand même la suite de
traitement qui qui est un peu notre lot
depuis quand même les débuts de
colonisation on est dans un air de
réconciliation mais on n'a pas encore
appliqué ou mis à coeur vraiment les
recommandations qui sont tournés vers
les femmes autochtones qui sont tournées
vers justement la discrimination
systémique dont on est victime et le
présentement il y a une demande non
seulement du leadership autochtone du
Manitoba mais aussi la population
autochtone de chercher ses femmes et de
leur offrir quand même la dignité après
le crime donc elles auraient été
victimes alors c'est un moment très
important je pense parce qu'on parle de
solidarité entre communautés à travers
les provinces mais aussi une solidarité
pour les femmes alors je vous invite à
vous informer sur justement cette
situation qui se passe au Canada et on
espérant que ce soit plus quelque chose
qui soit normalisé par aucune forme de
d'institution au Canada que sur la santé
que ce soit la police que ce soit en
environnement que ce soit un peu partout
qui est pas un double traitement qui est
différent pour les femmes autochtones
surtout parce qu'on considère que c'est
trop c'est trop compliqué elles sont
mortes de toute façon vous comprendrez
que cela un impact sur
sur l'identité d'une femme autochtone
alors je vous souhaite une belle semaine
et en espérant que vous partagerez cette
chronique et que vous n'hésitez pas à
nous poser des questions